the agony of a mother after a wedding
party disaster
Aisha adri's resident of Ebu survived
but watched helplessly as our three
children drowned images she says she
will take to our grave
as the boat broke I told my eldest
daughter not to jump into the river she
panicked and the rest followed her
our 20 year old daughter Fatima was just
a month away from her own wedding
lost nearly all his family eleven people
he showed me around once a home full of
life that suddenly became what he calls
a ghost house
I'm broken I have lost the will to live
what's there to live for anyway
tired of waiting for government Aid and
eager to find closure families and
neighbors resort to self up
the raised ill-fated boat from the
riverbed
the teams had expected to find
somebody's trapped in the wreckage but
when it was brought to the surface none
was recovered dashing the hoods of many
who wanted to give their loved ones a
proper burial
some of the victims were buried on the
bank of the river Niger
was a volunteer rescuer on Monday night
I now put one boy inside my boat this
little bit but I'm that I'm using so I
now turn his head down I press the
stomach I praise it again so the boy now
vomit water too much he now wake up like
this and start crying Mommy Mommy Mommy
and I told him that he should please
come down
in all he says he rescued recovered and
helped to bury more than 30 victims
the tragedy has decimated the population
of Abu Village 61 people died here
almost 10 percent of the population
the village of zakhan lost 38 people in
the disaster
Nigeria's president Bola ahmatinibu has
ordered an investigation and Aid to
present
both sinkings are becoming a regular
occurrence on the river Niger
dozens died in similar incidents last
year overloading and a lack of law
enforcement are often blamed and as the
community's grieve Villages fear they
will never recover from their loss Ahmad
Idris al-jazeera Equity Nigeria